france 24 y la unesco presenta
[Música]
bienvenidos a patrimonio en común un
programa especial de france 24 en
colaboración con la organización de
naciones unidas para la ciencia la
educación y la cultura unesco y estamos
en un sitio increíble en el sitio
patrimonial de cartago en el norte de
túnez y si estamos aquí es porque este
país hace diez años vivió una revolución
que sacó del poder a ben alí y una de
las grandes conquistas de esa revolución
en la libertad de prensa y la libertad
de expresión sin embargo organizaciones
como reporteros sin fronteras o amnistía
internacional alertan de que esa
libertad se encuentra en peligro y para
discutir sobre ello tengo tres invitados
frente a mí comenzamos por ti
natalia román morte periodista
independiente corresponsal para medios
extranjeros en túnez y presidenta de la
asociación de corresponsales extranjeros
en el norte de áfrica muchas gracias por
haber venido los seguimos contigo marta
luz sueño moreno doctora en información
y comunicación autora además del libro
nadie ayer y una conversación con una
ilustradora comprometida políticamente
gracias marta y nos acompaña también
mohamed
él es escritor de escritura español
hispanista de la facultad de letras de
la universidad de la manouba y además es
presentador de un programa en español de
la radio pública internacional de túnez
gracias
mohamed inversión antes de conversar la
revolución lo que generó sobre todo fue
una explosión de los medios de
comunicación en túnez inmediatamente
después de la revolución se calcula que
nacieron 12 cadenas de televisión y 35
radios vamos a revisar un reportaje que
hizo nuestro corresponsal aquí en túnez
se instala más ya al respecto y luego
conversamos
radio fm es una emisora privada y la más
reciente de túnez en poco tiempo ha
logrado tener una audiencia tan amplia
como la de 10 emisoras públicas juntas
es además la más escuchada en internet
de todo el país el informa al alza
batman y hable en tren sale facebook
alemanas adaptadas al original pues y
tellement femp sedentes gusta power fm
facebook save the head metraje idea
médica que retractar mus de main
múltiple o hacerme de hits expertos y
profesores universitarios especializados
en los medios tunecinos consideran que
aunque estos medios privados no están
afiliados al gobierno eso no implica que
sean independientes un alicate ciudad
que viera proyectan
al alma común según adelante hitn
quienes trabajan en los medios creen que
gozar de un ambiente de libertad no
garantiza que los del sector público se
desarrollen de manera óptima min hacer y
decir hey den cita sin almada min
le pedí el vidrio gratis el líder y el
ataque de el yuyu de final en el mueble
y ahí se generalizarán doha rentable
además los correcta salud prótesis
en túnez los medios audiovisuales
públicos enfrentan muchos problemas para
poder ser competitivos mientras que en
las instituciones privadas la toma de
decisiones es más fácil tienen además
una visión clara y un plan de acción
estrictos con el carrier que me lee
curtis absoluta y alejada al emplear me
de your int de infantes por la fifa y
llevo un head start a andar sin la dina
línea de muy evidente y león y es la
hija del talent tras la revolución de
enero de 2011 los medios fueron
liberados del control de los servicios
de seguridad así como de las decisiones
gubernamentales pero los medios públicos
siguen atados a la burocracia y no han
logrado ofrecer productos que convenzan
y atraigan a la audiencia
los medios públicos siguen atados a la
burocracia decía este reportaje de
nuestro corresponsal natalia pero antes
hablemos de los medios privados también
el reportaje decía que no son tan libres
como podría pensarse porque
efectivamente desde 2011 hay una
explosión de medios pero la cantidad a
veces no viene acompañada de calidad y
justamente esos 12 medios según
reporteros sin fronteras la mitad de
ellos están ligados de manera directa o
indirecta de partidos políticos entonces
al final sirven de plataformas
electorales o propagandísticas que lo
que hace es una polarización de la
sociedad de la política y por tanto de
la sociedad y ha hecho que pierda esa
credibilidad que necesita la prensa en
estos momentos en una transición
democrática como es túnez partidos
políticos pero también empresarios u
organizaciones religiosas marta también
se dice que están algunos en el control
de estos medios de comunicación hay
varios medios de comunicación como
aceituna que ni siquiera está
registrado en laica que sigue emitió la
ella que es la alta autoridad de la
comunicación audiovisual en turismo que
no se respeta y sigue
difundiendo todos los días y en realidad
también nos encontramos con todos los
medios religiosos que vienen de otros
países como de los países de las
regiones árabes orientales
entonces hay una hay un surplus de todo
lo que es religioso que se añade a la
política y también encontramos para
personas como nabil karoui que se ha
presentado a la presidencia la última de
las últimas elecciones presidenciales se
pasó a la segunda vuelta que pasó la
segunda vuelta que fue en prisión fue a
prisión un poco después
que tiene una cadena muy conocida y que
ha sido toda la propaganda alrededor de
su mandato o de su propuesta de mandato
mohamed eso justamente decía no cierto
natalia que la variedad no garantiza la
diversidad hay muchos tunecinos según
una encuesta de bar alemana ruiz search
del año 2020 un 66% de los tunecinos que
no confían en los medios de comunicación
es verdad que la libertad de expresión
está amenazada
pero yo me siento optimista sabiendo que
la libertad de expresión es el único
valor que ha conseguido valor
fundamental que ha logrado sobrevivir en
este naufragio de la revolución tunecina
quedan muchas cosas por hacer es verdad
pero
la corriente contrarrevolucionaria no ha
logrado acabar con este logro y yo me
siento como tunecino orgulloso de saber
que en materia de libertad de expresión
túnez ahora está en la vanguardia de
todo el mundo árabe
es verdad que
se cometen a veces extralimitaciones
pero es normal es normal porque en túnez
nunca se ha ejercido la libertad de
expresión ni bajo el colonialismo por
supuesto ni durante el túnez
independiente los gobiernos autoritarios
que se extendieron nunca nunca la
libertad de expresión ni bajo en el
túnez independiente ni bajo régimen de
burguiba ni menos aún bajo el régimen de
ben alí cuando cometan abusos
extralimitaciones pero es algo natural
porque es como un periodo de rodaje de
este nuevo motor democrático que un
periodo de rodaje que va a ser más o
menos largos sobre todo un país que no
tenía experiencia democrática antes de
la dictadura o antes de la revolución
cuando usted dice corriente
contrarrevolucionaria a quien se refiere
contrarrevolución yo como intelectual y
poeta independiente entonces lo digo
claramente la máquina
contrarrevolucionaria empezó a funcionar
apenas se escapó ben alí del país empezó
a funcionar pero que no tienen forma
esta máquina ha funcionado muy bien está
funcionando muy bien pero con otros
colores
la máquina ha cambiado de color y está
funcionando muy bien han conseguido
acabar con muchos logros pero
la libertad de expresión les ha
resultado afortunadamente un hueso duro
decíamos natalia que organizaciones como
reporteros sin fronteras amnistía
internacional decían que esta libertad
estaba retrocediendo de un espacio del
lugar 72 al 73 de 180 países es cierto
que no es tan grave como en el año por
ejemplo de 2010 que estaba en el 164 o
en el 2011 que estaba en el 134
reporteros sin fronteras dice que el
clima de trabajo se ha deteriorado que
hay violencias físicas verbales y
responsabilizó y por eso le preguntaba
tienes la máquina contrarrevolucionaria
a los partidos islamistas que son los
mayoritarios en el parlamento qué
piensas tú es verdad que el derecho a la
libertad de prensa y de expresión es
sabemos que es una lucha sin pausa pero
es verdad que en estos últimos dos años
estamos viendo signos que nos alertan de
que hay un retroceso principalmente a
partir de las últimas elecciones
legislativas y presidenciales de 2019 en
el que por ejemplo hay digamos tres
puntos negros
en el ejercicio de la prensa el primero
como ha dicho la compañera marta es el
monopolio de los medios de comunicación
por parte de hombres de negocios de
empresarios de políticos y en algunos
casos de los dos porque ocupan los dos
puestos y entonces claro tenemos
informaciones totalmente tergiversadas
en segundo lugar es el difícil acceso
que tenemos los periodistas a la
información institucional sobre todo la
presidencia de la república reporteros
sin fronteras habla de amateurismo de la
presidencia regla de cibeles me ha
recibido que está en una especie de
búnker no ofrece entrevistas no ofrece
ruedas de prensa y se contenta con tener
a su propio equipo que no sea luego nos
envía a los periodistas a los medios de
comunicación el vídeo comunicado de
prensa pertinente y ya no hay más acceso
a él y para terminar es el ascenso de
los partidos de extrema derecha y de la
extrema derecha aquí es el salafismo son
los islamistas no tiene porque son
populistas sobre todo tenemos todo tipo
de corte es a la fiesta pero también
totalmente neoliberales
y entonces estamos viendo como estos
partidos consideran que algunos
periodistas no compartimos su ideología
y no somos dignos de participar en sus
ruedas de prensa pero no sólo eso sino
que hay ha habido agresiones físicas y
verbales contra periodistas e incluso se
les ha tildado de blasfemia algo que es
muy grave porque eso es una invitación a
grupos de salafistas a atacar a estos
medios de comunicación y entonces en
esta situación el sindicato nacional de
periodistas tunecino ha lanzado un
boicot desde finales de 2020 para no
cubrir eventos políticos de dos partidos
concretamente el partido desturiano
formado por los nostálgicos de la
dictadura y el partido la coalición al
karama de corte ellos y reivindican
islam o conservadores son salafistas y
que hacen de su de su hacen del ataque
los periodistas una marca electoral un
market y tienes amigos en acierto que
han vivido situaciones así de violencia
si la verdad que cuando estoy trabajando
sobre los medios en túnez la dificultad
de acceso a la información
uno de los principales problemas pero
también la dificultad de trabajar no
tienen acceso a los materiales tienen
que buscar cómo ir a los sitios no se
pueden hacer reportajes en regiones
porque no tienen un coche
sufren presiones políticas y también
viven en un viven además de la previsión
viven la autocensura porque saben que si
se habla de algo puede que tengamos una
llamada en un final del día y que
tengamos que parar el periódico para
recomenzar otra vez y también
el sindicato de periodistas desde el año
pasado ha habido más de 500 personas que
han han sido despedidos de forma ilegal
hay más de 300 personas que dicen haber
sido abusados en el sitio de trabajo
incluso en mujeres en una manifestación
de snacks del partido de la amistad uso
sexual claro entonces la situación de
los periodistas no les permite tampoco
hacer un trabajo digno del nombre de
periodista y puede ser incluso con
cuando vas a las redacciones no hay no
hay la reunión de redacción por las
mañanas que algo que todos los
periodistas conocemos por las mañanas
llega ahí cada uno se reparten las
temáticas sin que haya una apuesta en
común de todos los periodistas de los
redactores jefes etcétera
efectivamente mencionadas también la
precariedad el sueldo de los periodistas
en túnez públicos oscila entre los 300
euros evidentemente también quizás eso
limita la libertad y justamente lleva o
invita a la autocensura
mohamed usted decía al hacer democracia
al ejercer la libertad de expresión y de
prensa se aprende justamente es uno de
los desafíos de los medios públicos
tienen que aprender de pasar de ser un
medio de propaganda
a ser un medio de comunicación usted que
trabaja en una radio pública pero
también hay temas con los nombramientos
de los directivos en los medios públicos
hubo dos sitting este año en la agencia
pública de noticias y en la radio en fm
porque los periodistas no estaban de
acuerdo con las personas que estaban
poniendo su cara o incluso intervención
policial eso también es un tema que
queda ahí todavía pendiente que lo que
decía antes quedan muchas cosas por
hacer hay que seguir militando tiene que
haber más sacrificios la libertad de
expresión no se sirve en bandeja
hay que luchar por ella hay que
arrancarla lo estamos consiguiendo poco
a poco gracias a dios'
la situación ha cambiado mucho
me alegro y lo digo otra vez me alegro
de que los tunecinos por ejemplo en las
redes sociales no solamente en los
medios de comunicación
en las redes sociales se están
expresando libremente usted lo dice así
usted que fue condenado y santo un
proceso legal por haber publicado una
crítica en este caso en interne tengo yo
vengo desde hace unos años publicando
unos poemas satíricos en los que
denunció abusos políticos vicios
sociales etcétera y efectivamente
fui imputado hace cuatro años y el caso
sigue abierto todavía imputado de haber
cometido ha cometido delitos delitos
punibles con penas de prisión es un
proceso penal no civil el fui imputado
de haber cometido el delito de
difamación
porque mira acusador
pretendía que se sentía aludido por mis
poemas satíricos se sentía aludido y
para colmo de la aberración él es
profesor de literatura e ignora que
lamentablemente que ni el lector tiene
derecho a entrometerse en la libertad de
expresión del poeta ni este el poeta
tiene derecho a ingerirse en la libertad
de interpretación del lector y el paraco
por lo peor es que fue imputado también
de haber cometido un ultraje a la moral
pública y las buenas costumbres por el
mero hecho de haber empleado en uno de
mis poemas una
la locución malsonante hijos de
compensar y la emplee en un poema
titulado eufemismo los h perfectos
motiven lo vamos a dejar aquí vamos a
hacer una pequeña pausa y volvemos
dentro de un ratito con nuestros
invitados y esta interesante
conversación
[Música]
france 24 y la unesco presenta
volvemos a patrimonio en común vamos a
volver a presentar nuestros invitados
con quienes conversamos sobre la
libertad de prensa en túnez la libertad
de expresión también natalia roma a
muerte periodista independiente español
en túnez y además presidenta de la
asociación de corresponsales extranjeros
del norte de áfrica estamos también con
marta luceño moreno doctor en
información y comunicación y con el
profesor mohamed 2 y escritora de
expresión española de la facultad de
letras de la universidad de la manouba y
además presentador de un programa en
español de la cadena de radio pública
internacional de pones gracias
nuevamente y mohamed es justamente
estábamos hablando de usted que tiene un
proceso en su contra por haber publicado
unas palabras que fueron consideradas
ofensivas por ciertas personas en túnez
pero eso forma parte de una denuncia más
amplia que ha hecho amnistía
internacional dice que justamente entre
el 2018 y 2020 sobre todo en internet al
menos 40 personas han sido perseguidas
como usted por haber publicado pueden
haber sido periodistas poetas como
ustedes que usted también se considera
opositor o crítico porque es un poeta
usted me lo comentaba fuera fuera de
pantalla y también simplemente
internautas han sido condenados en
función de leyes antiguas que eran de la
época de ben alí que no son leyes de
prensa son el código de
telecomunicaciones o el código penal yo
me quería hablar natales justamente el
caso de un bloguero el último caso más
resonado de este tipo de procesos y
desgraciadamente el caso de mohamed no
es algo excepcional blogueros y además
también simples ciudadanos durante el
confinamiento el pasado año hubo dos
jóvenes concretamente que fueron
detenidos y tuvieron que presentarse a
presentarse ante la justicia por hacer
críticas en las redes sociales sobre la
gestión del gobierno de la crisis
sanitaria y ahora de recientemente la
semana pasada hubo un bloguero que tiene
una página humorística en facebook que
se llama el ministro de la hipertensión
y que criticó al presidente del país que
caixa it y se ha visto no solo detenido
sino que además la justicia militar ha
abierto un caso contra el la justicia
militar y esto nos va a llevar a otro
tema importante una de las exposiciones
que hubo también con la revolución
es el auge de la caricatura no la prensa
del dibujo podemos decir de la
ilustración tu entrevistarte justamente
cuando te presentamos en la primera
parte a nadie ayer y que ha sido como el
símbolo ella es la madre del gato willis
will from atún es un gato muy crítico
muy inofensivo al parecer pero al
contrario tiene tiene muchas cosas
importantes varias verdades que decirnos
barta cuéntanos un poco efectivamente
hubo una explosión en túnez de la
caricatura sí claro que sí
al principio podemos verlo con el caso
de nadia el primer dibujo que nadie
publicó públicamente que lo hizo en
facebook fue a la salida de ben alí de
túnez y desde entonces no ha dejado de
hacer dibujos y no sólo ella hay muchos
caricaturistas en los medios medios
tunecinos pero también tunecinos en el
extranjero como zetas que sigue haciendo
sus caricaturas muy críticas con una
simbología muy tunecina entonces había
una apertura total de lo que se puede
hacer dibujando por qué
y el auge de la caricatura es que el
dibujo permite más el dibujo permite
mucho más y permite decir menos pero
sugerir más entonces hay muchas menos
posibilidades de que te ataquen
injusticia con un dibujo pero siempre
corren ciertos riesgos riesgo los
riesgos de que te ataquen
los islamistas por ejemplo los
salafistas cuando hay atentados
a la calidad de la religión por ejemplo
podría comentarnos esos dibujos que
estamos viendo si este dibujo es de 2018
sin dibujos de nadie de nadie gear y
representa a wheel frontones debajo de
la bota de la opresión que al principio
está wheel está callado durante ben alí
y luego claro durante la democracia
puede gritar gritar un poquito y luego
que la bota siga encima y esto viene
mucho el año 2018 fue muy difícil para
los los tunecinos porque salieron a la
calle otra vez para pedir libertad para
pedir que haya comida encima de la mesa
que haya trabajo y una represión muy muy
fuerte del gobierno y una de las razones
por las que nadie sigue haciendo este
tipo de dibujos cuál es el límite y es
que corren un peligro tú mencionabas que
quizás nadie al ser tan con los
siguientes nacionalmente se puede
permitir
quizás ir un poco más allá pienso en
saliendo por ejemplo de esos blogueros
que también decíamos hay muchos que
compartieron las cosas que hacían
referencia a la religión islámica hay
una línea roja en ese aspecto con la
religión en estos una línea roja
la detención de una chica por haber
publicado un salmo de la corona en
snatch aquí está aquí que publicó un
texto sobre el corona con la forma con
una forma y práctica que parecía una
sura y claro que nadie se puede permitir
y muchos otros no sólo nadie se pueden
permitir publicar ciertas cosas en las
que algunas veces podría ser chocante
para la población tunecina podemos ver
el dibujo en el que vemos ahora solo
quería quemar a todos los dejó túnez un
poco una crítica muy feroz y muy fuerte
y pasa un poco todo con los militantes
todos los que militantes que tienen un
espacio mediático muy presente tienen
menos riesgos de que sean atacados
legalmente y tienen muchas más personas
que les cubren las espaldas para poder
hacerlo en realidad también ese dibujo
me hacía pensar en cómo comenzó la
revolución una persona que se quemó a lo
bonzo al parecer esos suicidios
continúan también tiene que ver quizás
con eso el dibujo mohamed que usted
publicó un libro web o 12 libros en
realidad público que han sido ilustrados
con caricaturas libros en tiempo
usted quiere entrar en la movida de la
caricatura porque elegir el dibujo
yo no soy caricaturistas soy satírico
más bien pero intento de un modo
aficionado ilustrar mis poemas satíricos
con ilustraciones que yo manipule solo
pero no soy el caricaturista pero
quisiera dirigir una cosa yo no soy
partidario
es mi punto de vista de una libertad de
expresión absoluta
yo pienso que la libertad de expresión
ha de ejercerse de un modo responsable y
pacífico siempre
por ejemplo
y yo no sería partidario de qué
algo algunos al amparo de este derecho a
expresarse libremente se dediquen a
fomentar el odio la violencia o que
hagan apología de la dictadura
o que fomente la acción o fobia por
ejemplo
y en túnez la revolución se hizo más que
por el pan
con la dignidad y quien dice dignidad
dice entre otras cosas libertad libertad
de expresión los jóvenes tunecinos
salieron a la calle hace unas décadas
reivindicando dignidad y el carrito con
el metro que ciudadano por el suelo ya
que el vendedor ambulante llamado
mohamed buazizi ilustraba perfectamente
la dignidad de todo el pueblo hecho
originó pisoteada por el antiguo régimen
dictatorial de penal y mohamed usted
menciona eso yo estoy conversando con
algunas personas de túnez que consideran
que en realidad la revolución y quizás
va a ser duro lo que voy a decir en
realidad fue cómo pasar de la dictadura
de ben alí a una dictadura islamista y
son personas que consideran que la
situación económica en estos momentos en
túnez es muy difícil un país endeudado
con una alta tasa de desempleo sobre
todo en la juventud y son personas que
parecen dispuestas como a
y transar acceder en esta libertad
conquista que a ellos no les parece tan
real dicen por si el país estuviera
mejor económicamente yo creo que las
fuerzas contrarrevolucionarias de las
que ha hablado antes han concebido una
serie de estrategias maquiavélicas
camufladas para hacernos creer que antes
vivíamos mejor que bueno de hecho el
partido de los aliados de ben alí está a
la cabeza el partido de héctor ya no
miento califican a su líder como una
mujer coraje entonces ese es el peligro
el peligro es volver a caer otra vez
en los abusos del régimen dictatorial de
antes ellos es normal que con esta
coyuntura económica muy desfavorable
el país estoy sufriendo pero esta
máquina aprovecha este sufrimiento para
inculcar no es en la mente de que antes
vivir vivíamos mejor no es verdad estas
son las réplicas de un volcán y después
de la erupción de un terremoto más si
bien hay réplicas y usted habiendo
tenido sobre el proceso en su contra
usted se siente más libre hoy
personalmente prefiero esto
pero prefiero esto no me agrada lo que
está ocurriendo hay mucha corrupción
mucho abuso pero repito los primeros
responsables de lo que está ocurriendo
gente reaccionaria gente del antiguo
régimen y también islamistas por
supuesto pero no solamente los
islamistas hay que pensar que también
otros partidos de la oposición son tan
radicales y tan nefastos para el
porvenir de túnez túnez tenían una baza
dentro de todo el mundo árabe que
estamos perdiendo la moderación ya no
hay moderación solamente hay dos polos
extremistas que se están alimentando uno
a otro el pueblo tunecino nunca ha sido
un pueblo radical ni violento pero
estos dos polos que paradójicamente son
minoritarios están haciendo mucho ruido
y están acabando con la moderación el
tunecino es moderado un moderado de
natalia justamente en ese sentido quizás
esa radicalización se ve sobre todo en
la noticia falsa tan de moda como ha
tocado el fenómeno de las noticias
falsas a túnez
justamente esa multiplicación de medios
de la que hablábamos ha hecho que las
plataformas electorales que se han
creado pues lancen todo tipo de teorías
de complots eso es algo bastante
habitual de teorías de complot de golpes
de estado de rumores de todo tipo
entonces claro de un lado tenemos a una
población que no tiene ninguna
credibilidad en los medios y luego las
redes sociales que se mueven unas masas
no milicias de acoso hacia asia
periodista sólo hemos visto
recientemente dos compañeras que han
sido acusadas de ser próximas al partido
islamista simplemente por su ejercer su
trabajo y eso me hace pensar en una cosa
hay un medio que nació con la revolución
que es
es un medio que hace un periodismo
increíblemente serio con muchos datos de
periodismo marta que también tiene todo
un trabajo editorial para verificar y
trata también de ser independiente
económicamente ya sea dando servicios
paralelos para conseguir dinero y/o sino
lamentablemente quizás viviendo de la
cooperación internacional pero no vivir
de la publicidad ellos hablan de que ya
esa época de vivir de la publicidad
pasado es por ahí debería ir el futuro
del periodismo es un modelo que intenta
crecer ahora mismo pero que se enfrenta
a muchos problemas porque tiene una
dependencia real hacia las fundaciones
que los que lo financian pero tienen la
creación de contenido que al que no
estábamos acostumbrados en túnez tienen
están creando podcast sobre el contenido
muy muy profundo hablan de temáticas de
forma responsable sobre temáticas que
son un poco difíciles de abordar en
túnez como las libertades individuales
como los problemas que viven las mujeres
los problemas de las personas lgtb
etcétera etcétera
marta me gustaría en ese sentido
interrumpirte porque tú eres especial
justamente los temas de género en los
medios de comunicación sí ya quizás es
difícil de hablar de ciertas libertades
como es en el túnez de hoy hablar de la
libertad sexual yo viene aquí hacer un
doctorado para ver cómo los medios
trataban la cuestión de la
homosexualidad en túnez y gracias al
análisis de lo de los medios sobre todo
escrito según la evolución quiere decir
que no porque haya una evolución se
habla bien de la homosexualidad o se
hable bien de las personas con una
identidad sexual diferente con una
orientación sexual diferente pero hemos
visto como los los conceptos empiezan a
utilizarse conceptos que son menos
peyorativos por ejemplo no hablamos de
hablamos más de persona
homosexual luego vamos a buscar otros
tipos de conceptos que vienen que han
impuesto los propios militantes y hay
muchos medios que empiezan a darle la
palabra a esas personas que participan
mucho a la revolución digamos así a las
manifestaciones y que sufren mucho la
represión igualmente entonces ahí hay
una evolución hay muchas cosas buenas
que se pasan muchos muchos medios que
ellos crean sus propios medios por
ejemplo la asociación sam's cree una
radio que dura durante tres años en la
que se difundían cosas por internet
sobre el género sobre identidad social
es una será una asociación lgtb que se
implicó mucho en la mediatización creo
que ha sido la primera asociación en la
que estuvo en los medios todo el tiempo
reivindicando el derecho a estar mejor
representados en los medios el derecho a
no a no ser penalizado porque hay
recurrir a la homosexualidad está penada
en túnez por el artículo 230 y que puede
exigir entre una pena de prisión entre
un año y tres años y las personas que
son acusadas de homosexualidad pueden
sufrir actos de torturas como son los
testes anales
aunque túnez permitió que los iba a
parar el año pasado todavía siguen
efectuándose sobre las personas con bajo
órdenes del médicos y de policías y tú
decías que también son perseguidos son
perseguidos son maltratados por los por
las policías son maltratados en las
cárceles pero son capaces de estar al
frente y de ponerse delante las
manifestaciones aunque las consecuencias
son sean mucho mayores para ellos quiere
decir que una persona que va a
manifestarse si se sabe o se pretende
que esa persona tiene una orientación
sexual una identidad sexual diferente
diversas por decirlo así los policías
los van a atacar más fácilmente lo van a
arrestar y lo van a intentar enjuiciar
por eso por ese tema muchas gracias
marta vamos a confiar entonces esa
esperanza que nos deja sobretodo mohamed
que entre nosotros es el único tunecino
100% porque vuestro corazón me imagino
está también en túnez gracias marta
gracias natalia lo gracias mohamed
llegamos hasta aquí en este interesante
debate confiando en que la libertad siga
triunfando en túnez y nosotros nos
despedimos muchas gracias por habernos
acompañado sigan con la programación
habitual de france 24
[Aplausos]